[Music]
we all have that wacky friend who thinks
they're so I'll turn it because when you
ask what's your favorite Christmas movie
they reply die hard slow clap for that
guy in his crazy off-the-wall opinions
you're mental you are bet you're one of
those people who thinks the Star Wars
prequels with the terrible puppet Yoda
are better than the originals with the
also terrible puppet Yoda little does
your wacky friend know though that
there's an even better alternative
Christmas movie that movie is die hard -
die harder throughout this video I'll be
discussing why the seminal sequel has
more in common with the story of our
Lord and Savior than you could even
imagine so sit back your [ __ ] and listen
to my new crazy alternative answer I'm
so lucky me reason 1 it stars Jesus
throughout die hard - Jesus makes
several appearances the plot film
centers around rescuing a middle-east
inish man named General Ramon Esperanza
while some Liars may have you believe
that he is Russian or some other
nationality that America hated during
1992 I think that he actually symbolizes
Jesus our Lord and Savior persecuted
throughout the film we see that the evil
John McClane wants to put an end to his
holiness his holiday home and end his
return to freedom depicted as a villain
we see that the general or should I say
Jesus is nice to those around him when
he gives kind words to that soldier
while some would argue that he murders
the soldier I believe that he is in fact
filling him with the holy spirit and
sending him on his way to heaven
murdered much in the same way Jesus was
we see the great generals suffer for our
sins on Christmas and ascend into heaven
wrapped in a beautiful light reason to
the
she's in it one of the more modern
characters conjured up for Christmas is
the Grinch this heartwarming story tells
the tale of a grumpy greedy grinning
Grinch that wants to steal Christmas
from all throughout the original work we
see the Grinch go on a journey of
self-discovery as he learns to love the
holidays once more similar to this we
see the character
captain carmine Lorenzo turn from belem
to trusted ally as he learns the joy of
Christmas and murder starting off as a
cliched authoritative jerk you will fall
in love with Captain Lorenzo as he lets
you learn the joy of giving once more
giving traffic tickets that is this
brilliant depiction whilst infringing on
copyright reminds us of just how
Christmasy diehard 2 is reason 3 it's
set at Christmas I guess I'm beginning
to scrape the barrel a bit here but did
you know this is gonna blow your mind
that die hard to die harder is set at
Christmas you didn't well guess what in
fact it is so that's really Christmassy
reason for it has an old person riding
something in the sky during die hard too
we see a graceful old British woman on
her journey through the night sky before
she is casually killed in a plane crash
however had her journey been successful
she would have most likely landed travel
to a child's home and handed out
presents metaphorically she clearly
symbolizes Santa I just feel sorry for
her grandchildren who would have awoken
to the fact that not only was their
grandmother dead or that they also
didn't have any presence as they were
most likely all on the plane this
reminds us that Christmas is full of
tragedy to the perfect Christmas message
reason 5 - Shh - shut up mate - shut oh
look yeah if you're one of those people
who think giving die hard is an answer
for your favorite Christmas movie it's
really creative and unique then you need
to sort your sodding life out you're not
original you're not clever you're a
complete idiot billions of people exist
like you
is so special well you're not tell you
what mate
stop saying stuff like The Hobbit movies
are better than Lord of the Rings and
ant-man is actually bought popular than
Superman it makes you look like an idiot
desperate for attention with your
alternative opinions because you have
nothing else going on in your life
you're pathetic and I hope you have a
terrible Christmas anyway make sure you
subscribe my channel yeah thanks
so that was my list of five reasons why
die hard 2 is more Christmassy than die
hard 1 bit of a terrible video wasn't it
probably shouldn't have released it but
I did and I just want to say thank you
to everyone who's checked out my website
this year I've seen a huge increase in
traffic which is all down to you sub
thanks please like and share this video
to spread the joy of Christmas and I
hope you have a brilliant year
[Music]
you